hi everybody how you doing you good I
give you the amazing Winnie holo I think
we just both want to feel a lot of love
today don't we so we can have a relaxed
conversation and actually we want you to
join in as well so don't be shy okay
we're going to sit down you've got your
phone there does that mean we're going
to be doing like selfies and things like
that any takers any offices all right
love you
I must say actually the first time we
met when we were thrust together in the
most Awkward scenario for a photo op but
it was a really happy accident because I
had genuinely admired you I've actually
met you a few pounds which one is this
well this is at a party and we will work
together we kind of hear those together
yes but that's an interesting thing
really man has a good picture where we
don't mind having a picture and it was
such a good meeting I thought and I
really wanted to post a picture of you
on Instagram and then I got starstruck
refusing she's going to think I'm really
working in a bit desperate here so I
also must add that you were 2 years old
when I thought of my mother however that
does not mean that you haven't achieved
an awful lot
in your shorting bailing time and I
think many of you in here today would
know when is amazing collaboration with
Beyonce and in the spirit of Women's
International Women's Day this week I
think that's how you were really
properly introduced to a mass audience
and that's where we all got to know you
and be with you and be with you so you
have now become the role model and you
are a global phenomenon is that crazy I
mean
how do you feel about being older world
right so we know partially and a little
bottle yeah for me honestly but the term
role model means someone to be imitated
and I don't feel like anyone is to be
imitated I feel s I pull inspiration
from everyone and I feel like I'm
honored and grateful that people feel
like they can pull inspiration for me be
inspired by me yeah but I definitely
don't think I'm role model like I'm not
someone to be imitated I just assume if
you see me I love that hari is what I
think that's actually a very humble
state stance in pain because then I
think it feels like you're saying you
don't presume that you are in a way to
be copied or emulators and then perhaps
in the same sense that takes the
pressure off you because you're still
developing you're learning you're right
I mean not to be patronizing but you're
still at a pretty tender age yeah I am I
am
come on and people now it's amazing yeah
thank you you've done an awful lot and
what I love about you is that you're not
really easily categorized and that's a
wonderful thing because I mean you're a
fool I try not to be great yeah sorry
was I saying good I think we I think
people tend to categorize everyone yeah
you know everyone is put into a box at
some point of yes of their lives but I
find that I'm always battling that and I
feel that that will always be my my
battle yeah but I'm happy provide it I
get that is very empowering it's great
so to me you're a performer you are
willing and brave to try your hand at
pretty much oh my god and then you're
going to be a bunch of compliments I
mean this is all about you when Carla
that's why you're here after all and so
what else would you do if you could
collaborate on anything and with anyone
what would you want to do right now I
mean forever I've always been a lot
about beauty and products and skincare
makeup so if I was to do a collaboration
right now I think it would have to do
with skincare beauty products maybe
makeup I'm really interested in the
whole process being a manufacturing
distribution formulation LSF say you're
a businesswoman first and foremost which
is of course what we are but people
forget that yeah and I think we're quite
similar and we chatted quite a lot about
the idea of actually the most important
ambition of all is to be self sufficient
that is true independent and that's a
very empowering message I think a lots
of women and men in the audience today
so I don't know I mean do you want to
collaborate with me I mean can we
measure or can we get wrong Remini yeah
okay so Justin you're also a
spokesperson and you're an activist and
you're a prior fashion model too right
fifty-two ever for one moment imagine
you being a public liar or did it come
as a complete surprise
um Ruth true truth I think it was always
embedded in me that I was going to be
something from my mother especially and
because of that I think I wasn't very
much so surprised when I became a model
or when I started getting something back
with the hood out
it's a great way to make friends so it
is think we honestly a good photo
together though for not knowing player
we don't look like we don't know exactly
get in the way at the Solway orbit of
making friends with people going on yeah
you can feel quite shine you can feel a
little not sure of the other one and you
know way to come together so sometimes
when you have to use a guy but you never
met me never met before and then ever I
was madly when a stranger is a funny old
con section sorry we got off topic but
that's not unusual
that's pretty ok so so soon we're at
your parents have been supportive yes my
mother especially she always thought I
was going to be something and I remember
when I first started modeling my dad was
not for he wanted me to be in the
military and that's not morning can be
quite militant Iowa I did it though
because it was his way of having
security for his children yes so you
know education security all this so I
can appreciate the thought behind it
yeah my mom on the other hand was like
you know what a piece of advice that she
got from her father was do what you love
because you'll have to do it for the
rest of your life and Renee something
that she told to me from what her father
told her and my dad would be like now
she could never be a model that's like a
one-in-a-million thing I was like she is
one in a million she is Oprah she is
Beyonce she could do it all
thank you I would think with there's
there a bit of rain as well yeah and and
I think on behalf of parents everywhere
when your child does something
extraordinary it's something that they
have an experience for themselves
yeah and so of course there is a kind of
reluctance as well as enthusiasm but
generally I think moms do get a bit
giddy ecause my mom is exactly the same
yeah and it it kind of sucks sometimes
because you feel like ah dad why can't
you just support me but it really comes
out of a loving place of course it does
so I mean as I understood that because a
lot of times yeah like just support me
to see how what I'm here but I mean more
times when none is from a loving place
and today I have like a stash of almost
stalk romantic magazines of you in that
hand
my mom does and when I know like to buy
any of them should like yeah to buy them
for her because she is either
I like to buy my own food is a funny
anecdote my mom is that she brought
pictures of me that have been Toronto
fridge magnets and she keeps them on the
fridge at home mom very long
[Laughter]
right so we all now know what you do
what would you've done if you weren't
doing any Hollow
what would your alternative career be
what were your questions growing up I
heard you were ferocious reader such a
rose I love I need to get back into it
but as a child oh my goodness books were
like and get away it was like an
adventure I was a child who was like
always not in the corner like at school
but at home I would be in my room lost
in my room in the corner by a nightlight
reading all night to the point where I
couldn't get up for school the next day
cuz you enacted I was so tired yeah but
you knew more than everybody else at
school anyway presumably by that point
sorry they knew more than anybody else
books you die
no a lot of fun facts like I know a lot
of unnecessary information like you know
like super facts just like random things
but yes it's like a party trick in fact
it's kind of same thing I like that see
me at a party you know is that a promise
this is the promise so we've both also
had a pleasure working with Nick nights
and he's kind of beyond fashion
photography he's almost like a social
commentator isn't he and just the pure
art of beneficio artist I can't really
define him and you're a match made in
heaven you too because we can't define
you either and it's good to go through
different roles I think all in my
fashion guys later
he is your fashion godfather and he's
also one of the best models in the world
it's uncanny
he is isn't he she's using the way he
moves
oh yes I am that I don't know anything
pictures together though yeah I the
camera dreams everything moves yeah yeah
he's very grateful though you very like
beautiful man you know yeah yeah good
person and what are you laughing out of
front around you go questions
so what else what do you do in real life
I always think these are the really
interesting meaty questions what makes
you happy what is your style what do you
wear when you're actually not on the
runway
what do I wear well what do you know why
I mean I I am always in like sports wear
athleisure I am always in sneakers and I
feel like it gives me more more will to
go to the gym yeah if I'm already
getting close
oh I know you know it's hot isn't it you
know downtimes also gym clothes on in
the daytime and I won't ever end up the
gym though you know then you think well
I prove it I've walked up and down the
stairs and I mean you know the working
I yeah what do i do yes I love to be
with friends and family that makes me
the happiness but yeah what makes me the
most sad is being alone yeah it makes me
the most happy is being with friends and
family but then we're in the business of
being constant nomads yeah we are with
the guys on the road singularly
traveling to where the action is and
then tough so how do you combat that I
mean I love about your generation of
girls is that you seem like real genuine
friends and constants I mean you've got
quite a few super mod friends let's face
it yeah I am I think I I handle it by
being on the phone with my best friend
Oh like obnoxious we um I will FaceTime
her I will call her and get like my
late-night calls
all of the above I tend to be on the
phone with her a lot I'm actually trying
to get her to travel with me so
hopefully that'll work
cross your fingers from you guys are
just so fair with you everywhere if
you've got her on skype and things like
that
hey - I feel you general per argument I
feel you um right so come on have you
ever had any insane celebrity crushes if
so who has they've been and have they
checked all your boxes in real life no I
don't have many celebrity crushes to be
on I actually don't
umm-hmm no I know I can't like that I
think boys are cute but I swear we have
like crushes nice I forgot to meet
someone and like experience their
personality I'm like my cutest mates
like I just use them on Instagram blur
oh he's always lovely I don't
necessarily have a crush until like I
meet and I'm like can you get chatting
no I got shy I guess I it's easily done
yeah see you don't seem to be a person
that suffers with shyness no but if
there's a cute boy that I'm interested a
nice
today I think I'm over only one no
[Laughter]
that's very cute and in terms of having
mentors then let's take away the crush
and a boy element other women that you
look up to and do you have you I mean
when you first started for example were
there people that kind of took you under
their wing I wouldn't necessarily say
that anyone specifically took me under
their wing just because I feel like I
was stomping a new ground that had not
been tapped as as yet so there wasn't
anyone who was specifically taking me
under their wing I definitely looked up
to people though you know when a major
person being Naomi Campbell of course I
said yeah make sense yeah right that's
like a given and then I met Jordan Dunn
later on in my career and I was
absolutely infatuated with her she's
also of Jamaican descent she's from
South London yeah so we're both for more
you know edgy areas of our cities
similar like comrades yeah exactly and
women you love yeah we we meshed we
blended very well I mean you sort of
have your own face wings I don't imagine
you slept in under anybody else's any
time soon doesn't you do know me as
somebody that needs to do that not needs
to but even wants to something else
maybe you know it's it's nice to get
it's nice to have a wing it's nice to
give a wing in a cycle yeah absolutely
so in terms of shows and work do you
prefer
runway or do you like print work I
prefer a runway yeah
it's quick yes it's over right and I'm
quite supposing standing still that
whole static thing is terrifying
yeah and it's hot harder than people
like I think like I think after a day of
shooting it's like I've been working out
like for a full day like is that much
yes that
much work but can you explain how you
feel night I mean are you hiding in a
portaloo backstage before you go on or
what how does it feel
see that's the hard trade-off because
it's terrifying the exact ways just
knowing that you're going to have to
like walk that that runway by yourself
yeah possibility that you could trip
there is a possibility that you can fall
flat on your face in front of all these
people and cameras and sometimes live
campus yeah I know
I think a combination of determination
and vanity will always keep you on your
Fisher when nobody wants to fall on
their bottom in front of lots of people
it's what it's all so exciting and I'm
Michael over you want to do it again
yeah course and what is the most bonkers
show you've ever done like the most
bonds oh mike edward funkin um i think
so
longest yeah runway that I've done so
far was Mark Jacob uh-huh there's a very
long catwalk so that was awesome raizy
and then we walked out and hung out in
the winter cold in the org yeah so that
was fun
yeah but it was amazing yeah I was
aghast really brisk but it was amazing
though in a such a beautiful show I
think to show that I was maybe the least
nervous for would be well this season
would be Julien Macdonald yeah I feel
like that was just because he gave me so
much encouragement and so much like love
you know during the fitting and during
like right before the show who like I
need you to give me butene goddess and
sex and I was like okay I can do that I
can do that yeah I see my walk that was
why he is about the most enthusiastic
though if you yes I love it and I go -
absolutely so again what is next for you
you've achieved so much what do you want
to do what I want to do such a massive
on fair question it is huge
again I would love to work in beauty
products I feel like it's really highly
anticipated like people knowing how I do
my makeup
yeah Zomba yeah and and normally when
you do see me with makeup on and so I'm
doing my makeup today I I did not I was
blessed today but um but usually it is
me who does my makeup so I do have kind
of a love for makeup and beauty product
I would love to if you do a Vogue cover
one day or happy to glamour cover one
day even Victoria Secret that's a big
one you yes that would be amazing yeah
I'm gonna so golden chose the travels
they aim for something I think you need
those goals though I think if at any
point you feel you've reached a plateau
then it's time to appreciate actually
exactly so you are a success but what
actually took that word success mean to
you personally professionally I feel
like it means happiness because if I if
I achieve achievements and success I
don't feel are exactly the same if I
achieve a bunch of things I'm not I'm
not happy that's not success plenty not
happening succeeded in my life yeah
exactly it's not fulfilling so I feel
like happiness I feel like once again
like my grandfather I told my mother and
my mother told me to do what you love
because you have to do it for the rest
of your life
what's so truth now and finally in the
business of beauty which is why we're
all here
what does Beauty mean to you
Winnie Wu is the big question
what does Beauty mean to me what does
Judy mean to me I feel like it means I
feel like beauty is in the eye of the
beholder
so um it doesn't really matter what
Beauty means to me
yeah what's beautiful to you is not
which can be beautiful to me so I'm just
going to leave that one open
that's it thank you thank you very much
um I'm sure lots of you've got questions
for Winnie so many when you're ready
because you like - oh I think you look
amazing
you should be sat up here enjoying we're
going to get a microphone to you
actually okay right and this is the
question we want into our queue it's
right so major hardware you have to
overcome in the industry and why was it
your major hardware I feel like coming
into the industry
thank you yeah I feel like coming into
the industry I if you have any sort of
thing that makes you stand out or
different I feel like people
automatically try to put you in a box to
my client I can talk about yeah and I
feel like initially climbing out of that
box
I don't feel like I'm lost in that box
so much anymore but I do still feel like
people try to put me in there but the
initial getting out of that box I think
was my biggest struggle because I didn't
feel like I fit in that box and I feel
like I relate to everyone and not just
someone with vitiligo or someone who you
know I'm also a woman I'm also a black
woman I'm also I'm Aldo yeah a young you
know there's so many things to me that
don't have to do with my skin so I feel
like I relate to so many more people
than the boxes that people were trying
to put me in great questions by the way
and so essentially I think having you in
the spotlight is to absolutely help
redefine beauty stances and it's
incredibly important but do you think
those because I think or I think with
you and others in the spotlight there's
been a shift in the beauty industry in
terms of what we do find beautiful and
how we and what we perceive as beauty do
you feel that shift in from the position
of working in the industry thank you
I definitely feel anxious actually there
was one point where I really felt that
ship although I've been feeling it
recently I well actually previously I
met this young girl named April and she
also has a little I grow and I met her
on on a TV show in the States
they surprised her on the show with me
with Tyra I think I've seen it sorry was
it with Tyra no no okay no no it was the
real yeah and she you know she was
really excited to meet me she cried I
cried as well it was amazing and she was
like no I tried to be a model and you
inspire me and you've been inspiring me
and I've seen her for a long time I've
seen her on Instagram and I've you know
posted her and all all all sorts and as
of recently she she just did a gap
campaign and I I was I was so excited
and so proud because that's something
that I would have never seen as a child
you know it's amazing to see me on these
covers and everything but once again I
am I am 22 which is not old by any means
but to see a child with a job or a child
with vitiligo or a child with with
freckles
it shows the change in the industry you
know it's not just adults which yes
we kind of have a we kind of have a
voice as adults to make changes but
children don't so the fact that our
voices are now making changes for the
children that are coming up is showing
the change in the industry
one more question or leaving are you
yeah hi I'm I don't have a question I
just want to say as a one Jamaican woman
to another thank you for being here it
is great to see you and you know I think
it's important I have two daughters and
when I was growing up I didn't see women
like yourself so prominently in the
industry or in media or anything I just
like to say thank you for coming to do
the talk and thank you for everything
that you do thank you for what a rocky
where is amazing honestly I can talk as
much as I like where there wouldn't be
anything with know you guys well thank
you for all lovely I think we should go
get a drink
like let's go thank you for having us
work we're being booted off so yeah
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]